à la Réunion non ils ne font pas ils ne
font pas cette cette opération
directement ici c'était déjà dur à gérer
de de savoir que son petit va se faire
opérer mais tout ce qui est autour c'est
compliqué aussi c'est vrai que pour
quelqu'un qui qui connaît rien à cette à
cette pathologie et ce qu'il doit faire
avec son enfant qui est encore bébé bah
c'est c'est dur et c'est choquant chaque
année près de 900 réunionnés adultes et
enfants partent en transfert sanitaire
lorsque des examens ou des soins
thérapeutiques spécifiques doivent se
faire hors département dans un hôpital
de l'Hexagone une convention
départementale est signée avec les
organismes référents le CHU la cgssr
l'UDCCAS et le département pour une
meilleure coordination des services afin
que ces malades et leurs familles
puissent bénéficier d'une prise en
charge
optimale une fois la pathologie
diagnostiquée et le traitement médical
établi le CHU informe le patient et la
famille du projet thérapeutique et des
modalités du transfert sanitaire
l'ensemble des des communications des
des des transferts d'informations qui se
font entre l'hexagone et l' de la
Réunion est fait par nos soins entre
nous médecins et servicees de l'hôpital
le le patient n'a rien à faire il ne
doit pas se s'inquiéter de la continuité
de cette prise en charge qui est faite
de manière transparente entre nos deux
nos deux centres l'assistante de service
social de l'hôpital accompagne le
patient sur la mise en œuvre du
transfert médical elle fera également le
lien avec le service social de l'hôpital
receveur l'assistant du service social
de la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie et du département ensemble ils
vont traiter les documents
administratifs préparer la logistique
afin d'accompagner au mieux le patient
et l'accompagnant dans cette épreuve de
vie c'est la direction régionale du
service médical qui valide les demandes
d'accord préalables pour un transfert
sanitaire si les conditions sont
nécessaires la demande de prise en
charge d'un accompagnant est également
sollicitée si cette demande est validée
une évaluation sociale et administrative
de chaque patient et de l'accompagnant
et est réalisé par les assistants
sociaux de l'assurance maladie on va lui
lui donner un espace d'écoute pour pour
poser ses craintes ses peurs et comment
il va anticiper cette démarche de soin
hors de lî parce que souvent c'est la
première fois qu'il part et et c'est là
qu'on va travailler sa
représentation sur la santé la peur de
mourir comment je vais gérer mes enfants
derrière mon épouse mon mari qui reste
et aussi bah quand je pars travail quels
sont mes droits est-ce que j'ai droit à
un complément de revenu qui va prendre
en charge mes soins mes frais de
transport mon hébergement la nourriture
les frais de viture donc là nous on est
là avec lui pour lui lui expliquer qu'on
va essayer de sécuriser tout ça et
anticiper au maximum tous les risques et
tous ces besoins auquels il devra faire
face dans le cadre de sa démarche de
soin une prestation légale permet la
prise en charge du billet d'avion et des
transferts pour le malade et
l'accompagnant c'est le service
établissement qui s'occupe de ces
réservations en lien avec l'assurée et
ensuite à nous de communiquer à l'assuré
les billets électroniques et cet
accompagnement et cette volonté aussi au
niveau du service social de faire
systématiquement une évaluation pour
l'accompagnant à la fois de l'assurée
qui doit se faire soigner ou de son
accompagnant pour que ça soit ça se
réalise dans les meilleures conditions
et l'objectif justement de cette
convention est d'optimiser encore ces
accompagnements socials entre le Conseil
départemental la CGSS la direction
régionale du service médical il ne faut
pas oublier bien évidemment euh le CHU
un dispositif extraalégal octroie sous
conditions une aide financière prise sur
le fond d'action sociale de la CGSS pour
aider à la prise en charge d'un
hébergement et des frais annexes pour le
malade et l'accompagnant le service
social examine chaque situation pour
actié si nécessaire cette aide aux
personnes en situation
[Musique]
précaire face à l'urgence d'un transfert
sanitaire et à la précarité de certaines
familles des aides complémentaires volon
AR peuvent se rajouter au dispositifs
réglementaires ces aides peuvent prendre
différentes formes et sont proposés par
les centres communaux d'action sociale
nous sommes tenus donc d'organiser la
réponse sociale notamment l'urgence
sociale et les familles viennent nous
nous rencontrer pour avoir un complément
d'aide sous forme financière la plupart
du temps et quelquefois ça arrive aussi
sous forme matérielle c'est-à-dire une
petite valise pour pouvoir voyager ou
éventuellement une pour payer donc les
l'ébergement au niveau au niveau du du
de l'endroit où la famille va se
retrouver donc dans
[Musique]
l'Hexagone en avril 2022 le département
s'engage à améliorer le dispositif du
transfert sanitaire en complétant les
dispositifs d'aide pour le premier
accompagnant la collectivité pour
préserver la cellule familiale et
l'entourage du malade propose la prise
en charge d'un second accompagnant deème
accompagnant est très important parce
que en fait ben on garde ce cocon
familial là parce que déjà C doit aller
déracinés a des fois des personnes qui n
jamais pris l'avion déjà quand les Gilot
ici l'aéroport on un peu perdu imagine
Arve à Paris na rien à voir l'aéroport
c'est vraiment des grands les et le fait
de pas être tout seul ben c'est c'est
quelque chose de rassurant au G il
demande alors où ta vie enfin voilà
c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose que
les vraiamis expliit va peut-être
comprendre ou pas mais il faut vraiment
vivre ça avec les famille pour
comprendre qu'il est important de faire
notre maximum pour déjà les
améliorations que nous a pu apporter et
vraiment fait notre maximum pour
continuer à apporter des améliorations
les travailleurs sociaux du département
rencontrent ce second accompagnant
accueillir la parole une écoute
attentive pour réaliser une évaluation
sociale afin de mettre en place le
meilleur dispositif d'accompagnement
possible c'est le cas de parents dans le
cadre d'un enfant hospitalisé où le
premier parent lui et obtient le
transfert sanitaire de la part de la
CGSS et le deuxème parent vient
solliciter le département afin de
pouvoir justement financer justement ce
ce voyage le l'aller-retour en billet
d'avion de la personne un hébergement et
si besoin et une aide exceptionnelle
voilà et c'est en lien avec l'antenne de
Paris que l'accompagnement se construit
sur place l'assistante sociale du
département assure un soutien logistique
et humain au plus près des personnes
bien souvent perdu et isolé dans cette
situation c'est une dame qui sort de
saasie qui n'est jamais vraiment sorti
de chez elle et qui est arrivé ici et
qu'il a fallu que accompagne
physiquement
régulièrement en plus son mari a changé
deux fois d'hôpital donc à chaque
déplacement d'hôpital donc je
l'accompagne pour lui montrer comment il
faut faire pour prendre le bus le métro
pour arriver jusqu'à l'hôpital
puisqu'elle fait tous ses allers-retours
chaque fois que son mari est à l'hôpital
le rôle et la coordination des
assistants sociaux prend ici tout son
sens et toute son importance pour
apporter une réponse efficace aux
familles la collectivité active un
numéro vert dédié le 0808 800 247 et une
astreinte au
0692 974
800 le CHU mais aussi la CGSS le
département ou les CCAS doivent se
coordonner et se mettre autour du
patient que ce soit le patient ou même
sa famille pour organiser au mieux ce
transfert le patient étant déjà
préoccupé par par sa maladie et la prise
en charge de ses soins faut être encore
plus efficace pour être plus efficace il
faut que le champ d'action de chacun
soit bien clair que la population soit
au courant de ce que l'on fait donc on
va communiquer plus et puis on va
communiquer plus auprès du grand public
et on va communiquer plus en interne
pour que chacun sache comment on va
travailler ensemble ça c'est important
coordonner pour être plus efficace pour
l'usager c'est ça l'objectif de cette
convention cette convention engage les
partenaires pour une optimisation des
aides et un meilleur accompagnement des
usagers lors des transferts sanitaires
au cœur de cette nouvelle organisation
les travailleurs sociaux de chacune des
institutions point de convergence de
toutes les démarches administratives et
de l'accompagnement
humain